Death from overwork kills Japan's overstretched workers with heart attacks,...
...strokes from mental stress, malnourishment,...
...and some workers even take their own lives.
A survey by the OECD found Japanese middle school teachers...
...work 56 hours a week,...
...compared to an average 38 hours in most developed countries.
That doesn't account for the massive overtime hours spent cleaning,...
...supervising school commutes to after-school clubs and other tasks.
I have things to do outside school too, including family responsibilities,...
...so I sometimes get snowed under and feel pressured time-wise.
But even when I am under pressure, I don't reduce my workload at school.
I enjoy the time I spend playing with the kids, and I just cannot stop.
An investigation by a union-affiliated think tank...
...showed school teachers work an average 123 hours of overtime each month,...
...pushing their weekly workload well beyond the dangerous 80-hour threshold,...
...which labor experts call the karoshi line.
Teaching is often seen as a sacred job devoted to children,...
...but there are growing calls in Japan...
...for teachers to stop pushing beyond their limits.